yeah yeah just looking out for a little
guy
this is what it is
you're gonna forget who i am
what are you hiding
peter i'm very aware of your tactics and
my rights you know whatever even if it
did hurt i'll let it bite me i knew way
before mj did i was spiderman's guy in
the chair
we come in all shapes and sizes this is
what we do
we help people hey you know what maybe
you should invite him to liz's party if
you want to read about our inspiring
friendship you can now in my new
flashpoint marry iron man and kill hulk
go get him tiger
am i waiting in the car i need a minute
uh under advisement of council i refuse
to answer the question
you are amazing yeah i mean like i had i
took a photo of the debate team and
you're in the debate team if it's
personal i don't want to like pry but i
just think it's cool power beyond your
wildest dreams we don't need you to save
us
we don't need to be fixed
precious tritium but i need more of it
this time
you're not peter parker